what's the emergency there a car just
went through my neighbor's house okay
and very fast because it's like in the
second room and I don't we don't we
don't know what people are just clearing
up the stuff here so that the car went
all the way into the house yes
like 10 feet into the house now is it
safe for you to get next to the patients
somebody is doing that right now okay
because somebody's going there now was
anyone thrown out of any of the vehicles
it doesn't look like it it's got the
flash is gone it's got the door open
we're making communication
foreign
because they're kind of Trapped in the
front door somebody's trapped by the car
we've got lots of help already coming a
lot of help on the way now can you
safely get next to that person that's in
the car
yeah
it might be a host okay I'm gonna get a
hose it sounds like the person who ever
stretches that it might be okay is the
car on fire
it might be I don't I didn't explain
somebody just said good good water okay
let's let's go back and find out if that
house is on fire is he awake can you
find out if the patient's awake is the
patient awake yeah
the house is on fire now
thank you
what part of the car is smoking
what what is smoking it's a lot of
smoking it's big enough it's um so is
the car catching on fire
yes
okay
okay get everybody out of the house can
you get that driver out of the car
no
well
is there anybody touching the car
okay I gotta stay on the phone with you
okay I see the fire truck just right
here I get the driver out of the car if
we can but I need you to stay in a safe
location don't put yourself in any
danger let me know when the fire
department's there and taking care of
the emergency
they're there now